hello thank you once again for clicking
on my face you know what i really love
in life
good food nailed that segway to the
sponsor of this video this video is
brought to you by hellofresh hellofresh
brings seasonal recipes and fresh
pre-measured ingredients right to your
door they offer a wide variety of quick
and easy recipes 20-minute meals easy
clean up low prep options making cooking
fun not a chore as i've mentioned in
other videos i try to be
health-conscious at this phase in my
life so i love that they have fit and
wholesome recipes and for me the cherry
on top i personally
ate going to the grocery store so the
fact that they have all the ingredients
all the content for the meal delivered
right to the door that's not to put to
find a point on it chef's kiss so click
the link below go to hellofresh.com use
codepogjejohn16 that's p-o-g-j john's
16. for up to 16 free meals plus three
surprise gifts across six hella fresh
boxes plus free shipping and thank you
once again to hellofresh for sponsoring
this video i do appreciate it now we
talk about the movie that everyone is
talking about totally it's just all the
online chatter
this movie it's not it's
that's me trying to talk it up i would
be baffled if this video gets a hundred
thousand views when i watched the movie
and i was like that is video worthy i'm
gonna talk about
[Music]
so the adam project is directed by sean
levy stars ryan reynolds of course it
does like director sean levy was like
right you remembered scorsese and
dicaprio in the mid to late 2000s
me and ryan reynolds he's my guy it
starts out briefly in the year 2050 i
believe and ryan reynolds has stolen a
jet that apparently can go through time
goes back to the year 2022 accidentally
he didn't mean to go to the year 2022
but here he is he's trying to stop
something from happening and so he teams
up with his younger self
and now they're on their adventure also
surprisingly enjoyable and a thing where
this is kind of a buddy movie of a kid
and his older self or older person and
his kid version of the cell they're all
teaming up to go on an adventure i gotta
say the pairing of the kid and the adult
to be the same person was actually
really good young ryan reynolds
character and ryan reynolds who i would
call ryan reynolds character but it's
ryan reynolds you take a ryan reynolds
character from the past 10 years it's
gonna be this guy but the pairing was
great the kid felt like young ryan
reynolds ryan reynolds is [ __ ] talky
self and this kid is younger [ __ ]
talking self he's gonna become ryan
reynolds so ryan reynolds gets to
lecture him because we would all do that
whether it be five years ago 10 years
ago 20 30 years if you could have a
conversation with your younger self to
tell that younger self chill the [ __ ]
out stop that thing stop doing that in
those situations we would all do it so i
enjoyed seeing that in this movie if you
can't do it in real life it's fun to
vicariously have that fulfillment
through entertainment it's kind of what
it's there for sometimes because their
dad
it's really confusing i'll say the kid
version of the character his dad died a
couple years prior i think a year and a
half is what they say in the movie brian
reynolds is like how you're acting
you're gonna regret this for the next 30
years just be nice to your mom she's
trying i enjoyed that you know if you're
gonna have a movie that's just like oh
yeah time traveling adventure you know
like we've seen it all at this point
this is gonna break new ground i'm
always pleasantly surprised when they
can bring in a really nice family
dynamic of reconciliation where i could
be like hey i didn't get behind that
that's nice also funny enough the dad
played by mark ruffalo the mom played by
jennifer garner i know what you're
thinking you're like oh elektra was
married to the incredible hulk and had
deadpool as a kid no where i'm going
with this this might very well be the
unofficial sequel to 13 going on 30.
that's right they're not all comic book
references on my channel sometimes it's
13 going on 30. as for the action in
this movie the action was fine you got
ryan reynolds has brought some future
tech from his time he's fighting some
futuristic stormtroopers at d cloak
right in front of him so he has a
lightsaber but not lightsaber which is
funny because the action is very visual
effects heavy and sometimes i was like
oh that looks really good and there's a
d aging thing that happens with one of
the characters i was like well it's
that's right they don't have that mcu
budget in that very same scene one of
the characters was standing on the green
screen i was like whoa that that looks
like my green screen you can see the
green right it's doing that man that
green screen around the hair that was
happening i was surprised at the fun i
had with this movie i think if you're
looking for an enjoyable fun sci-fi
movie with a good family dynamic and
family lesson you and the kids might
want to sit down and watch it was like
late 90s early 2000s early to mid 2000s
adventure also i feel like i should
mention it's i always say oh fun family
adventure there's more cursing in here
is pg-13 be mindful of that
not like i don't get [ __ ] it's not for
me though it's for informing parents i
try to be mindful of that because i'm an
uncle now and that's how uncle jeremy is
that's right being an uncle's made me
soft whatever already made my 13 going
on 30 reference there's no one doing
this in terms of ryan reynolds being his
ryan reynolds self in the comments
section of my videos i could feel like
people are like yeah i'm kind of done
with that until deadpool 3 because
deadpool's one of those characters one
of those movies was like yeah
that's fine directed by sean levy
director of this movie so you know
because they're the team yeah in the end
i think it's an enjoyable time fun time
no alcohol required it's a movie for
youth doesn't treat kids like they're
stupid all right so the adam project
have you seen it what did you think
about it or what's your favorite family
adventure that you still get into as an
adult whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you